Keeping persona's in mind when
you're designing a product,
how does accessibility
play in the persona's?
>> Well, like with all persona's you
want those to be based on information
from talking to real users.
And so again, is no different here.
So you want to go out and actually talk
with people that have these impairments.
And when you're developing your persona,
some key pieces of information that you
want to include are,
what is their impairment?
What is the severity of it?
How do they kind of tackle and
get through their daily
challenges with the impairment?
What are certain assistive
technologies that they use?
What's or how experienced are they
with those assistive technologies?
What's their skill level?
>> Mm-hm.
>> You want to talk about what
are their pain points in trying
to achieve tasks that
are related to your product.
The whole goal is just to really
try to get in some important
insights into how they go
about completing tasks,
and what are some of their different
approaches that they might take that
maybe other users that you've
already spoken to haven't.
>> And what if I don't have
access necessarily to someone who
has an impairment, like who else could I
contact, or how may I get that insight?
>> Well, you'd be surprised at
because there is a wide range
of impairments like again,
if somebody that has just kind of lower
vision versus somebody that's completely
blind, you probably do know somebody
with some sort of impairment.
And just thinking about
an older relative maybe that
has lost a bit of their vision or
has arthritis and
their level of dexterity
isn't as what it use to be
that's really valuable in sites that you
can talk to them about or somebody who's
not a native speaker of the language
that's prominent in your app.
They have to kind of approach
things in a different way too,
that could be really insightful.
So there's a lot of people
out there that you might not
immediately consider talking to,
that would be really valuable.
>> Great.
What companies have you seen that
have been designing for all users and
especially with those with impairments?
>> So,
stepping out of the digital world for
a minute, I think two great examples are
the Bradley Watch, which is right here.
The Bradley Watch was designed
from the get go thinking about
people with impairments, at least with
the visual impairments in particular.
And so what this watch allows
you to do is tell time
with just feeling the watch.
And you can see there's two magnetic
balls here that indicate the hour and
the minute, and
this is obviously great for
people with disabilities in that
it helps them tell the time, but
it also is visually appealing,
it's very aesthetically pleasing.
And it doesn't look like anything
very different than other watches.
So it doesn't draw attention
to their disability,
which is always an added bonus
to these types of devices.
But then just thinking about in
situations where if you are sighted,
you might be in a dark movie theater,
or in a meeting,
or discussion where you don't
want to take your gaze away and
you want to still understand what
time it is, it's really valuable.
>> Yeah, that's great.
>> Yeah, so you can see, this is
a great example of thinking about
those needs upfront and coming up
with a great product for everybody.
>> And the other one was Oxo.
>> Yes, and so,
Oxo design is that they have a whole
design team that focus on universal
design, which we talked about before.
And some of their products always have,
are always keeping in
mind different needs.
And so some examples are, they talk
about this again on their website where
they can use a basalts
bender with one hand, or
their measuring cups are really unique,
in that you don't have to kind of
bend down to see where
the liquid is measuring.
You can look over and
see where the numbers are.
So they take a lot of
things into consideration.
Again, it benefits all users,
not just those with disabilities.
>> And to wrap up, what are you
final thoughts on accessibility?
>> I'd like to say that yes,
it can be daunting.
It can be time-consuming if it's left
to the end of the design development
process.
There's always a lot of retrofitting and
rethinking that needs to happen
if it's left to the end.
There's no doubt about it.
So, to save everyone time and
pain, think about it early.
Think about throughout
the entire process and
just incorporate it into
your existing process.
And in the end,
not only will you have saved time.
But you will also come up with
a much better product that's usable
for everybody.